welcome back to cbs mornings it does not
take a close observer of politics to
notice some distance you might say
between president biden's goals and his
achievements so far in the fight against
climate change now that's partly because
of objections within his own party and
in particular objections from senator
joe manchin
well now mr biden is considering acting
without waiting for support from
congress ed o'keefe is at the white
house for us ed good morning senator
manchin's my mom's home state senator so
for her and for all of us what's
happening here
well tony good morning with the
scorching heat here across the united
states and in parts of europe it does
appear as you said that the president's
climate change agenda is on ice up on
capitol hill it is unlikely to advance
in congress now that west virginia
democratic senator joe manchin there he
is said last week that he couldn't
support the plan because of concerns
about inflation and the cost and scope
of the proposal he of course represents
a coal producing state so that's part of
the reason why he objects so today the
president's expected to say that if
congress isn't going to act you're going
to try to take some steps on his own
white house says he's not going to be
declaring a national emergency on
climate change at least not yet he's
still thinking about doing so instead
he's flying up to massachusetts to do
two more modest things one he's going to
tout the offshore wind industry very
popular there in new england as they're
building windmills off the coast of
massachusetts and he's also going to
talk about boosting federal aid for
communities trying to fight the heat by
retrofitting homes and stalling air
conditioners and other issues if at some
point the president decides that he
wants to declare a national emergency on
climate change it's likely going to
allow him or at least attempt to try to
regulate carbon emissions even though
the supreme court recently ruled that
the environmental protection agency
cannot do that
notable that he's waiting to possibly do
that later this summer because there's
still a chance that joe manchin can be
convinced to allow democrats to move on
at least some of the president's climate
change plan we'll see
nate
ed thank you